welcome to this 15-minute game yes 15
minute game again let's see Sparty on
Sparty husband if I pronounces correctly
from him I'm India ok so I'm going to
play an English opening here with black
well that's a quick 95 to take that it
is really quick it's not uncommon to
have 95 plate but normally it only has
played when um when there is a knight on
c6 that's attacked by the pond coming to
d5 so that black has to move the night
again here this is not the case ok I
guess this is the right diagonal afford
the bishop anyway I wonder yeah okay I
wonder if if I can can and should do
something with a five year or if this is
the sermon a stupid idea ok I will play
85 first this this looks like a move
that should always lead to a favorable
change of pawn structure for me if he
takes the a pond is weak if he does that
I get some ideas with the piece coming
to see Five the night or possibly also
the bishop has a place now and b5 is
upon that can become a liability um for
that matter what about a for you
this interesting a form if I just attack
the pond to see able to defend it I know
this is very simple chest like a for
Bishop d7 rook air-five Queenie 8 you
might be able to defend it 97 it's also
not bad let's do that let's play play
simple chess 97 and maybe f5 f5 Knight
f6 my bishop has a good spot on b6
anyway it's not I mean what spot is it's
a little bit it's not really correct
it's looking at this pawn only 3 which
is not that great but it is outside the
pawn chain at least and it's not a
liability of some sort and in the long
run this piece might get to get active
again yeah this is a move that I
expected and I wasn't sure what to make
of it if I take it I think this is
something that white ones nighty night
takes d4 496 I'm going to do this here
and this cuts of the d5 pawn that's very
important yeah you can do that but still
the night after Queen what about Queenie
aid actually attacking b5 and
introducing g5 into the position yeah
that's not bad it looks at b5 it also
protects the e6 square so that 96 just
loses a pawn yeah and again here g5 is
possible 96 I will take and play d 5
then
I will win the six pawn not sure about
all that I can also play a for first
which is interesting it isolates this
this pawn on d5 I think this is a good
intermediate move odds vision sook may I
have that this is good how does he even
yeah there's this move but now g5 is
even more interesting because after 96
takes pawn takes d5 d5 comes with the
tempo yeah he runs right into this
surprisingly and now after Queen takes
is 6i will just be a pawn up for really
not much Joe you six will fall what I'm
not completely sure of as if I ever take
is sex is f3 a move that I should be
concerned about or not really now I can
take them I was thinking that I could
insert g4 to prevent f3 not bad really
but also not really necessary um I can
do various things now the bishop on b6
is very nicely protecting c7 it's not
doing much more but this is important so
let's do some improving moves look up 7
as a good a good Universal move
preparing further who gave a tire so
he's actually actually opening him so
I'm taking an idea for was my what was
what I was thinking but that's not the
only way to play I bet okay it's it's
it's it's good yeah let's just do that
and use the new square on d4 for the
night yeah here Queen ephors even
possible yeah and I am it's nothing
terribly great one one thing that is not
that good is that I cannot easily play
rook hf8 there's the a pawn always
hanging and Bishop before it's also a
reply to look ahead it's not not ideal
well at the moment he really I mean what
is it does he have any anything great
iam maybe G forum maybe g4
I cannot take this hmm
I don't want to play G for myself this
looks a bit silly i just mentioned
rookie evade what i would like to play
runs into we should be formed
I was thinking about Bishop f5 the
system move or is it that a stupid idea
the rukon f5 is really misplaced that's
not really great hmm yeah not it's not
that easy here not that easy what Roy
did I do something wrong here I mean
it's surprisingly surprisingly difficult
ok what what is it what what else I can
do I can take the tool but this this
looks really wrong rook e8 may be
intending g4 and 92 yeah I don't know I
have to play move at some point I don't
feel that this is so great but oh ok if
you place g4 I thought f4 yeah if he
takes Bishop g4 check it should be you
should be good somehow what if that's
not so clear
you can clearly not take on a for as d2
hangs so that's not on me but you can
play Bishop b4 maybe
so we should be 4g for dads not it's not
clear none of that is to clear hmm okay
maybe I should have played g FOIA this
was my initial idea now that no I cannot
believe that move I can play g4 rook f4
and I can take on g3 that's that's not
going to work now I cannot believe it no
absolutely not
takes on g3 I mean that's not going to
work the only thing that looks a little
bit very similar at Bishop d5 would
really win the house but he cannot
really I don't see how he how are ya
quickly threatens d5 ok it's on this
with the bishop but I mean queen 8 who
were you can play I can play c6 looks
like that and in the meantime there is
really just just f1 hanging and 90-92
threatened
now I guess he has to play rucca 1 F 2
after that I will probably just hop back
to you form under yeah I just just have
gotten the Pawnee I on g34 no particular
compensation yeah or less than that
actually okay so he's are not minding
the exchange okay going to take that
right there is no direct problem or
anything with it so what now I wonder
what about c6 and Bishop f7 yeah I think
this is the right solution it just it
just keeps some d5 protected and Bishop
c7 is coming to to get nurse king also
Bishop see 78 f for coming yeah that's
good i guess my pieces are a coordinated
quite well rooks and queen they they
work together well that protect the
pants d 5 f-5 and so on and Bishop c7 is
a good way to activate this piece it did
only had a defensive role and will now
come to c7 attacking the rook and yes
supporting further play there yeah
Bishop c7 was the plan there is really
no reason not to play it the rook will
drop back now I guess
and now how I do I proceed I can play
Bishop g3 just take age form yeah there
is there is no reason not to the big
point is not so much that I get the pawn
which is nice but I also get to switch
over to to g5 to a techie 30 it's not in
trying to protect edge form I mean okay
couldn't protect it I'm sorry I thought
rook g2 but it doesn't really make a lot
of a difference okay I'm taking this
okay yeah he's now on at five but I have
to Bishop Bishop g5 and also Queen g3
which is quite good graeme 26 for Queen
g3 not let's let's start with that
checking III with a check
check check yeah there are some big
checks here in the mix queen age 33 g 3
and so on okay so yeah yeah I can just
play pawn to g3 and that's it you can
take on f7 trying to get a 96 check but
isn't that is leading to nothing that
wasn't altogether that clear now looking
at this I think and maybe should have
done something to yeah to to combat this
f3 move I thought that f3 would just be
good for black because I get this player
against III but I'm not totally sure I
mean this this kind of move is probably
not the best move but it really makes
sure that I really I just have a pawn
now for absolutely nothing and I can
play this in the long run there's also
this kind of idea which is far more
powerful maybe this is this is the way
to go threatening the immediate win so
he has to take here and maybe something
like that that's a very aggressive way
to play maybe not bad but okay I don't
think that this should be should be
terrible I again the comp suggests a
form that's an interesting move
yeah computer wants to use this this
bishop p.m. more actively by undermining
III it's far more aggressive than what i
did i mean my my plate preserved an
advantage but it probably wasn't so
clear yeah Mr good move c5 interesting
something like that is really terrible
now III is a huge problem and c5 take
stakes and tending Bishop c7 and and
this kind of rules yeah that's very good
okay yeah H foursome is really giving
the game away he definitely is not lost
yet I mean black is better but with most
like this he can definitely try to fight
on I mean I have those ideas with g4 rc6
Bishop c7 but it's not lost yet or
anything but ok the computers is already
really low have for white rook f6 for
instance with a clear yeah it's not
really a good position so in the game he
went with age 4 and this is just losers
straight away it loses the house iam
okay well thanks for watching